scene 1 take 1 with it Youngblood yo
what's going on GQ is young boy and
these are my essential items is my pink
socks and the area and we have a lovely
example and yes I love pink socks I
first got them on just because I wanted
something I could wear everyday that
kind of made me stand out a bit so I had
never taken off like legitimately the
basically should be told I would tell
them if I could oh hang on a beach in
the bath and shower on a run
yah mahn pink socks next stop is me gold
chains man and never take these off this
is like a st. Christopher that my Nana
gave me after she died
this actually been through World War one
which is crazy her dad had it so it was
in the trenches and stuff I was like
that's crazy so it'll keep me safe when
I'm on like flights and bosses and belts
Thank You Nana for keeping me safe I
hope your eye out there causing trouble
[Music]
York City Pass me the tea man always
your chatty essential as hell you just
could have a cup of tea no matter what
mood you're in
if your passion exams if your album goes
to number one if your goldfish dies just
a perfect thing and I'm from Yorkshire
so you got it's a very specialist tea
brand I would teacher I make one if you
want it's kind of a bit of an art you
put your tea bag in you put your up wall
or any let it brew for about a minute
you squeeze the spoon on at the tea bag
so you get all the tea out and it a
little splash of milk two sugars take it
up to bed in the morning start your day
off teabags
inhaler I've got really bad ass Smurfs
so like I give everything on stage man I
always try and be as energetic as I
possibly can but then I got off stage
about a satellite and the penguin off
Toy Story it's not me when he's like I
just say this and I'm fine I just need
it right now what's up nerds eyeliner I
love wearing eyeliner I love wearing
makeup I just like the way a feeling it
hey I was actually really young I
remember going in the school disco once
and my mom was straightening my hair and
I was painting my nails black and I had
eyeliner on and I way in a Nirvana
t-shirt and the skinny pair of jeans and
the teacher was like what are you doing
I was like you wish you looked this good
I'm so psyched to teacher at 9 or 10 I
don't think makeup should just be a line
to one gender I think no matter wha you
can express yourself you want to wear
makeup if you want to wear a chicken
suit if you're in just what about making
it my show you can't rock a roll express
yourself
and speaking of gender fluidity sir pass
me my dress this is essential to me man
I've been wearing this on stage my
Victoria Secret night it with my mesh
top I just feel like I look good in a
dress on stage it makes feel sexy just
because I'm a man biologically doesn't
mean a collar dress and I hate the way
we've put boundaries on ourselves it's
like women were dressed because this
accentuates body that means woman can
make baby it's like [ __ ] that my nice
self very evil just like wear a dress if
you want wear whatever you like rock and
roll up all rise thank you so much so we
have a mesh top and I wear this but
getting it ons a nightmare it's like
girls I don't know how you do the cross
I'm always just like this look my tour
manager is a girl so she always has to
help me into it so I kiss yes for now
boom Sh I am Tom come on in
tom is my videographer photographer
therapist all-time best friend and he
looks like a Renaissance painting we
call him King Louie he's from where I'm
from is from Yorkshire it's very
essential to me yeah what you get my
little VHS camera yeah don't worry it's
like a documentary
no he's pump I just love it man because
young blood isn't just me
I am 50% of what young what is the other
50% is my community and and things that
go on inside it it's that safe space
where people can be it's the two boys in
the crowd if you like that can kiss here
because it's safe or it's the girl whose
parents didn't understand that she
wanted to shave her head and tie to a
face what he or she feels like she can
be accepted or last week someone went
through a transition and they feel like
they can be themselves here and I never
want to miss a second of that Johnny
it's like a baby's been born you don't
want to miss a second a bit growing and
it's where Tom comes in look it's a bit
of a vortex in it's like I'm filming you
while you're filming me scoot back get
out of here
thank you Tom I won't clap for Tom over
Elm
next door creepers with favorite stylish
shoes ever I was obsessed with the Teddy
Boy movement the fashion in the 50s and
60s I just love that a lot man I look so
cool and I don't know I just my favorite
shoes it is part of young bloods lot you
know I mean it's like pink socks chains
creepers stripes and a dress and I put
on a pair of shoes a [ __ ] cheating on
my partner you know it feels weird and
get some creepers there are
so I tried to bring a puppy into the
building but the won't let it in I love
dogs I just click you and give you
cuddles and share I just let bleachy
wish I had a puppy right now it's like
Hello
but I don't summer start stroking the
magical pieces like licking my face like
dog stop and stop licking me every like
me I'm a puppy and oh god like I said
once Liam Gallagher was a puppy in a
world of cats
I've never related to a statement more
in my life fairness like be serious
darling I'm just like Harry bells Harry
boat and fast sticks it's like a German
UK company from a place called
Pontefract and that's about like 20
minutes from where I grew up and these
sweets are like super sugary I'll get
them out and what we do is a little
trick fear you just take one of these
sweets put it in the freezer it gets
freezing cold it feels amazing your
mouth and just not sweet enough I'm too
sour so bad sweets on me all time what
it's weird
so you got you dummies for your baby
your hippos coca-cola bottles but you
just can't beat the cherries also with
famous mmm finally everyone's gonna
think I'm so greedy and fat cuz I'd like
like food Chinese food I think it's like
a tradition what kind of a I grew up
with in my house Friday night if you've
been good article wait you like all
Chinese food and watch TV if I come home
from a long tour if I have a long show
just feeling the chopsticks in me
islands main feel like I've done
something right Oh what's my go-to order
I love beef Cantonese style with noodles
and just a bit dog talking it's okay now
mmm stop it's like great Chinese food
when it was just [ __ ] good up there
[Music]
Cheers GQ that wasn't my essentials I
hope you liked the video lots of love
hugs and kisses one